the war in ukraine has forced over two
million refugees out of the country
among them tens of thousands of africans
mostly students the attempt to flee has
been a harrowing experience for many
they've described the bombardments the
long journeys to safety and cases of
racism along the way
we've been talking to some of the
students caught up in the conflict
one nigerian who gave his name only as
chinedu was stranded in his house as
russian forces launched an assault
he sent us a video a few days ago from
the town he's studying in sumi in the
east of ukraine as you'll hear shelling
started while he was speaking to us
we don't have any ways to go out
we have been stuck here
no movements they keep bombing even
though they say no ceasefire they are
still shooting
let's see we don't have clean water we
don't have gas to cook
we don't have any food stuff again you
only eat biscuits sometimes when you see
biscuits bread
no food in the stores again
we don't have anything again
even this morning to my greatest
surprise my school provided three bosses
for only chinese students no bosses for
african students like i don't understand
are we not playing the same school fees
these people they just don't value us at
all they just want us to stay here and
die
we'll just be
i don't know if you guys can hear they
don't shoot us now they say that's his
favorite those photos
and we can confirm that chinedu did
survive the shelling on the night when
he recorded that video for us
and he later made it to hungary
now also now safe in budapest in hungary
his fellow student bisola we talked to
her about her experience her escape from
dinipro also in the east of ukraine then
on to leviv in the west and then later
on to budapest in neighboring hungary
i started by asking her when exactly she
realized she had to leave
from thursday to friday we didn't sleep
we couldn't sleep we couldn't eat
we were scared the tension was getting
more
hour by hour okay friday came in
the same thing we were like okay let's
still wait to see
if something was gonna happen but then
the intention was increasing
literally like i'm not like we literally
could not eat we literally could not
sleep like there was no peace like no
rest at all even shot in our eyes was
like a wrist because we didn't know what
was going to happen
so saturday morning
because zaparoja is just one hour one
hour applause to the nip danny pro so we
started hearing from zappos that the
russians were trying to evade we're
gonna evade soon and people in denial of
other people in their neighborhood like
they were leaving and all that so i live
with two other people um two other
friends
right i have two other roommates over
three so we're like okay we cannot stay
we have to leave because everybody's
leaving and then from if the russians
when the russians invade zap before you
know what they're going to come into
denibro and then we can't stay so that
was wrong we decided that we were going
to leave
okay we decided that we're going to
leave yeah
right you made it to to hungary
eventually
how did you make it there
we had to struggle our way through it
all
like
we have to struggle our way through it
all
all right so
when the initial plan was actually to go
to poland
was going to go to poland but then
when we went to the train station at
denipro train station there were a whole
lot of people who like the place was
full
so
they weren't sending tickets to us first
of all they went inside to get to us
blacks
they said you have to enter with tickets
the winner selling tickets to us they
were only selling this guess to
ukrainians
all right so we thought we we thought
okay what what can we do we have to
leave we can't stay so eventually we're
gonna have to push our way through all
right the train came the train came
with our lords
it was like we're just going up and down
because they were telling me telling us
that it was it was here it was there so
like it was a struggle we're just going
up and down up and down finally go to
the train finally got to the train you
know they said that we couldn't enter
that we couldn't enter because we didn't
have tickets and we're telling them that
you guys would not allow us to you guys
will not sell tickets to us i know
you're telling us that we cannot enter
because we don't have tickets so there
were a lot of guys a lot of african
african guys black guys so they were
trying to push their way in but you know
that these people this the police
literally went inside the train to bring
them out like bring them all out but the
ones that could fight their way like
fight their way
and fought their way inside deep inside
so they couldn't go deep inside but the
one that couldn't go deep inside the
train they literally went inside to
bring them back to bring them outside
and we we girls i literally because i
like me and my roommate crushes the girl
we fell down because of the struggle and
everything so we couldn't get on that
train so when the train finally came and
the train was coming from zapposia
because where our friends you know we're
on the train so they were able to also
keep seats for us
and help us so that was how we had a
struggle like we had a fight we had to
literally struggle and fight to enter
inside that trade even as much as we
should enter the train there was nowhere
to sit down there was nowhere to see
that like literally people were standing
people were
sleeping on the on the bypass i don't
know if you end up drinking not the
bypass who was sleeping there who were
sitting there and all but because our
friends you know kept it for us from zap
so that was how i was able to i were
able to push through push through to go
meet our friends where we where we um
where they were and that was how we were
able to manage to sit down because
obviously there was no space to lie down
we had to sit down and the trip the
journey from denipro to leave was like
18 hours in the dream 18 hours after all
the struggle we hadn't we had not eaten
we hadn't slept 18 hours you're in a
safer place right now
um what's next for you
what's next for me like it's literally
really complicated because now the eu
from our um from the news yesterday now
the er is saying that they can't
accommodate us students that they are
only acting as a pass by where students
can compass and go back to their country
so it's really really complicated for us
so we're trying to see within the short
period of
two weeks that we have which school is
going to accept us because we can't even
get our transcripts because of what is
happening in ukraine we don't have our
transcript but they don't seem to
understand that we don't have
transcripts we don't have transcripts so
like the like so it's it's it's really
really complicated for us like
the next step is really really
complicated for us you know
so uncertainty about the future uh well
um
thank you for speaking to us and we hope
that you're able to find a way forward
for the future
thank you so much